voilà monsieur bonsoir trois jours après
la profanation du cimetière juif de
carpentras s'est déroulé ce matin sur
les lieux même une cérémonie empreinte
d'une très grande dignité
le grand rabbin de france joseph sitruk
a voulu dans son discours d'une certaine
façon ramener à la raison ne laissons
pas dire n'importe quoi est il affirmé
isolons ceux qui sont antisémites et il
a conclu en accordant son pardon à ceux
là même qui ont perpétré cet acte
criminel
pardon à leur insu a dit le rabbin car
ses hommes ont montré les limites de
leur impuissance et leur incapacité à
vivre avec les autres reportés à patrice
blais jean-françois changer silence et
recueillement carpentras ville morte
pour un quart d'heure ce matin comme
associé à la douleur à la prière de la
communauté juive au cimetière se
pressait une foule jamais vue ici plus
de dix mille personnes
hommage et dignité une matinée d'émotion
pas toujours contenu trop de souvenirs
trop de révolte pour se taire on me dit
je n'ai jamais parlé
vous savez ce que c'est logique il faut
qu'on sache que des gauchistes ou brûler
tout cramé alors il faut plus jamais ça
disons plus jamais grâce ici ma b qu'on
lit
la vengeance ou le pardon le grand ravin
sitruk a choisi au nom du peuple juif
dans un texte d'hommage à félix germes
ont exhumé de son caveau est violente et
cette semaine nous venons te demander
pardon au nom de la communauté juive au
nom de la communauté nationale au nom de
l'humanité et au nom de tes agresseurs
qu'il soit et c'est peut-être leur plus
grande peine
associé à leur insu à ce pardon ce qui
nous importe c'est que la france
démocratiques d'aujourd'hui comprennent
qu'il ne faut plus laisser faire que la
grandeur d'une démocratie ne se définit
pas par la beauté de ses principes mais
par son obsédante quête de vérité
ils disent
je
l'espérance est un trésor